why does finland want to join nato
good morning kay thanks for having me um
finland has been a neutral country for
many decades
we never
forgot about the threats of our eastern
neighbor
we never were part of the soviet union
because we have fought wars against
russia and the soviet union in our past
but now it's uh it's a different time we
saw that
our neighbor has become even
more aggressive more unpredictable
and we feel it's it's the right time to
join nato uh which we have been
partnering with for for several years
already
i think
at the end of the second world war
finland ceded about 10 percent of its
territory
to the then soviet union just to give
our viewers an idea of where your border
is and also the concerns that that you
might have
is it because you're looking towards
ukraine and seeing what's happening
there
we have very very strong solidarity with
the with the ukrainians but of course we
need to make our own decisions based on
our geopolitics as well
and we feel that it's the right time to
join nato now and send in the
application as soon as possible just
like the president has said this morning
yeah and is it as a direct result of
what's happening in ukraine
it's very much a result of what's
happening in the ukraine
we of course um in the past 30 years we
have been members of the european union
uh and we have uh very strong defense
forces ourselves uh we have a very
strong defense cooperation with not just
not not only sweden but several nato
countries as well in like the uk
the united states
um but um
following the events um in in ukraine
and the brutal invasion
of russia in ukraine we feel that um
it's uh it's just a logical situation
now to to join nato uh to to partner up
uh
with uh
with our friends and our allies in in
the west we are a western country we
have been a stable democracy for over
100 years and together we are stronger
in defending our common values
um
what do you say to the argument that
potentially makes you more rather than
less vulnerable
because we've heard of actually we had a
representative from the russian doma on
the program a couple of days ago during
the victory uh parade through victory
day in um in moscow and he was saying to
us that if nato armory found itself on
finnish soil once you became if you
become members of nato that they
wouldn't stand for that because they
would feel threatened
well
nato is the defense alliance and
we are not there nato is not there to
threaten anybody
um all
nato members so far just like finland
and possibly sweden also
in the future uh will
have joined nato based on their free
will of the free will of the people
we are democracies and we want to defend
our values that's as simple as it is um
finland has very strong defense forces
and uh one of the strongest army in
europe not only in relative terms but
also in absolute terms
um we are happy to contribute to to the
overall security in europe uh and to
nato overall
yeah i think i might say am i that alina
that
you can roster what two more than two
hundred thousand personnel in response
to any emergency
that's right and if we take all of our
reservists then we have uh closer to one
million um that's right and uh what
comes to um to russia and their possible
response well finland is a sovereign
country and we are free to make our own
decisions
uh and whatever happens we are prepared
uh conscription i think i'm writing
saying is still used
in um in finland and the majority of
finns contribute in in some way
and undergo regular training as you were
pointing out there what is it that
finland is bringing to nato
well we can defend our border
as it is already by ourselves um and uh
if it becomes a nato border well it has
been a european union border with russia
for 30 years already we can do that and
we are also happy to
contribute to the overall
security and stability in the baltic sea
area
together with sweden together with the
baltic states
and to defend our common common values
in in the region
um
we have a strong army um there was a
trend some 20 30 years ago for
european countries to
start divesting their militaries
we've never done it we have always taken
security very very seriously and we have
a very strong capabilities in
in traditional military uh but also in
cyber warfare so
we are happy to to bring uh our
competencies to to the pool of nato
yeah just a final thought before i let
you go if you'll indulge me please um
elena what is there any difference um
between the older population and the
younger population in finland when it
comes to its view of russia
i think the younger population perhaps
has
felt freer in in criticizing russia and
seeing russia for what it is uh the
older generations of course perhaps
already themselves themselves but but
also their grandparents
still um have the experiences from the
second world war uh and the threat that
russia has
um has been to finland
but
now we can see in the polls that the
very strong majority of finns
um
roughly 70
support nato membership so it's no
longer a question of generations